you've gone to comic-con several times
Breaking Bad better call Saul these are
some of the most intense television fans
in the world these people idolize these
characters as they should
what's the fandom like at comic-con
because there everything is elevated you
know 80% heightened reality people who
walk on the street to get where they're
going to get to the big hall see with
five to seven thousand people and it are
all dressed I've had some really
incredible comic-con experiences I was
at a comic-con in 2016 and I'm sitting
behind a table signing autographs right
here my line is snaked around the block
Oh braggart
my dad was a carpenter but he wore some
good clothes so I'm looking down the
line there's a guy coming at me and he's
really handsome he's about six feet tall
and he is pulling up his pants as he's
coming toward me and I said wait this
doesn't look right something's wrong he
gets to me and he badges me he takes out
a badge and goes law enforcement and I
look at him and I just do my best custom
pression I say hmm I do like law
enforcement I give to the fun-run member
of the community well the guy goes on
and on and on he said I love your show
and he's giving me all these accolades
he says I got to show you something he
twists his leg around he pulls up his
pant leg and from the bottom of his knee
top of his knee down to his ankle is a
most incredible tattoo of Walter White
oh wow so I turned to him without
skipping a beat and I say you know I'm
not interested in him at all I'm not
interested in that I'm only interested
in him and you if you have me somewhere
on your body he looks sad he looked at
me actually walked away two years later
I'm back at comic-con sitting behind the
desk guys rushing at me guys familiar to
me he says remember me I said I sure do
he starts to I said wait no no no no
don't do it don't do it don't do it he
says no I got to show you this I got to
show you this he hikes up his other pant
leg and on his other calf is the most
incredible tattoo of Gustavo Fring with
half
face-to-face gun-happy based on that's
nice so I say to him I said very good
now you're even you are complete my son
yeah they go on and the world fans are
great I've tell you it's not the first
time I've had people come up to me with
tattoos on their bodies and I say I
think to myself what will happen when
they die when their body is examined
they go who are these that's the second
time in this show that a guest has
brought up being exhumed and there but
there's something where there's a theme
tonight you're obsessed with people's
butts being examined in the afterlife
yes I am
[Laughter]
you